[Music]
so last Friday the progressive website
Mother Jones included me in an article
about a quote new extremist media
industry that is further to the right
than Breitbart in the piece the author
referred to me as quote far-right citing
interviews I've done with Mike Serna
[ __ ] my Logan AAPIs and Lauren southern
to back up his accusation he cherry
picked these guests to fit his narrative
yet somehow missed the endless amount of
liberals I've had on the show and some
of the progressives I've hosted as well
including Margaret Cho Hilary Rosen Mark
Duplass John Fugelsang and Michael Ian
Black the article also attacked patreon
the crowdfunding platform which myself
and my team livelihood depend on for
being tolerant of people with quote
far-right views such as mine though of
course nowhere did it include any of my
purported far-right views earlier in the
week Forbes called the Rubin report a
conservative talk show but immediately
retracted a statement when I contacted
him ironically I've been saying for a
while that defending my liberal beliefs
is becoming a conservative position
although I don't think being called a
conservative is somehow a pejorative it
clearly isn't a proper descriptor for
this show in which I've hosted people
from across the political divide for
Mother Jones to accuse me of being an
extremist further to the right of
Breitbart is obviously an inflammatory
and demonstrably dishonest statement
I've been around many people over the
last few years who've been unfairly
maligned and I'm all too familiar with
how this goes whether it's sam Harris
Jordan Peterson Colin Moriarty ayaan
Hirsi Ali or Brett Weinstein each attack
is virtually never based on what these
people have said but is instead crafted
out of straw man arguments with the
words racist and bigoted tossed around
like candy
suddenly the onus is on the people who
aren't racists or bigots to disprove
this accusation usually slung by a
misguided celebrity or a malicious
newspaper or website the move then is on
the accused should they spend the time
and energy defending themselves from
accusations which aren't true a
to bring more attention to the
accusations themselves or should they
ignore them hoping that the false claims
will go away over time I think there are
solid arguments to be made for either
tactic and it truly depends on the
situation at hand and the person
involved in this case involving me I
went on the attack I decided this case
was too egregious to ignore and I
contacted the article's author via
Twitter screenshotting pieces of his
article and asking him to defend them of
course he couldn't defend his own words
that's the thing with truth it's hard to
work around and eventually he made
slight changes to the article like
including a tweet of mine in which I
defended myself from his claims and he
removed the word far in front of the
word right before referencing me in the
article putting aside the rest of the
specifics of the article itself I was
happy to get a strong defense in public
from many friends all over the political
map people like Joe Rogan Colin Moriarty
Faisal Saito Matar brett weinstein eric
weinstein michael shermer
peter Bogosian and many others offered
strong defenses of me just as I've
offered for others when I've seen them
unfairly attacked I even got a public
defence from Donald Trump jr. putting my
friends in public allies aside though
it's incredibly inspiring and humbling
to see literally tens of thousands of
people offer their voice when they feel
you've been unjustly attacked and that's
the key to this whole thing it's not me
or Sam or Jordan or Brett that they fear
what they really fear is that all of you
will start saying what you think because
their strength in numbers by Monday I
wanted to put this whole story behind me
my dog had a health emergency which
actually put this whole thing into
perspective but I admit I did get sucked
back into the story very briefly over
the course of another Twitter exchange I
got the writer of the piece Josh Harkins
in' to publicly admit that I am NOT
further right than Breitbart
though of course he didn't change the
title or have Mother Jones issue any
sort of public correction one other
interesting piece to all this is that
the writer Josh Parkinson is one of the
40 people that James Hodgkinson the
shooter of the Republican baseball team
last week in Virginia
on Twitter now I can't draw a direct
link there but we know that Hodgkinson
was afar lefty who was obviously driven
to political extremes so we miss very
same writer does a hatchet job on me
calling me further right than Breitbart
which is clearly a code for racist I
can't sit back there and take it this is
exactly why I've been saying you can't
punch Nazis call everyone you oppose a
Nazi in a racist and then eventually you
will see violence as the next logical
step it's not a crazy exercise to think
that this is partially what drove James
Hodgkinson in hindsight his attack on me
was the next obvious step in where this
whole collectivist movement is going I
talked for a long time about how if you
can't debate ideas you use lies and
buzzwords having it turned on me
shouldn't have been a surprise
especially from a leftist site like
Mother Jones yet somehow it did still
surprise me make no mistake there is a
sink position going on here and it can
come for anyone at any time if you ally
yourself with people who value the
movement in this case a political
movement over you as an individual then
eventually it is inevitable that they
will come for you and if they don't come
for you you're probably the one coming
for them this think juez ition will come
after anyone who bucks the trend in the
stereotypes and dares think for
themselves
it's why they accuse ayaan Hirsi Ali of
being anti-muslim
it's why they slander Bill Maher as
being a racist it's why they call Larry
elder and Uncle Tom and it's why
apparently they can brand me a far-right
extremist those who are a part of this
stink position fear you thinking for
yourself that you won't bow to their
collectivist demands more than anything
else the way to beat this witch-hunt is
to be yourself and fight for what you
believe you are the antidote that they
fear most I hope it next time you see me
fighting back and getting some cover for
my allies it will inspire you to fight
back
specifically with words not violence as
well joining me on the show this week is
one of my affer mentioned allies and a
friend and author and professor Peter
Bogosian who's going to help me dissect
some of the madness of 2017 and much
more joining me today is an author and a
professor of philosophy at Portland
State University and a man who strives
to be a good human every day he ever
goes here and welcome back it's a great
buddy here thanks and thanks for the
striving to be a good human you'd never
know it from what people have been
saying about us absolutely well fairly
you back me about you you've really been
through the wringer in the last few days
and I would love to get to that and talk
about that respect we can get to that
but strives to be a good human being the
reason I threw that in there yeah
because that seems to me you were on the
show about a year and a half ago and we
had never met before that we've since
become very good for her again hit a we
hit it off instantly
yeah just like that and when you were on
the show and we'll link to it down below
so that people can see the initial sit
down I felt that it was one of the
episodes where so many of the things
that I had been thinking about about the
left about politics about religion and
but so many of the things sort of all
came to get right I actually they really
did and I felt I felt richer after and I
do often in some interviews some
interviews I feel Dumber but this is one
where I I felt richer and since we've
become friends but you do strive to be a
pretty decent I do is you know you said
how should I introduce you in the
beginning and I was I don't ask that
normally the only reason I asked is
because we're friends and I yeah maybe
there's some personal little antidote or
something that you like yeah and I
really you know it's I really just
striving to be a good person I think
that's one of the things that matters
that kindness that compassion I think
we've so lost it and acrimonious it was
so hyper-partisan we're so and the
college craziness and everything that's
been going on and at the attacks and
people don't give you an opportunity to
respond to those attacks and the
negativity on social media so yeah I'm
just trying to be a good guy yes trying
to live my a good life a good life so in
the last couple months right you lost
your dad
I did that was the seminal event of one
of the seminal events of my life how do
you stay a good person throughout that
not not that it's not that losing
someone's going to make you a bad person
obviously but a mom you know you're
still
trying to work you're still trying to be
a public person and to write no like how
do you manage not just going nutty in
the course yeah I had some health issues
I was in emergency room three times the
last few months I have Crohn's disease
so that that's not doing me any favors
either if everything could be by me you
were in the hospital today yeah yeah I
don't know what tell it you know that's
my demo stuff going on but I can open
about it knowing and I think that that
that really does make every moment of
your life precious and when my my dad
died and my mom died I don't know it's a
kind of a combination of feeling more
circumspect and and I've always had in
the back of my mind
my parents approbation of what my dad
thank or my mom think and it's kind of
really given me an opportunity to I'm
trying to frame it positively it try to
given me me an opportunity to reflect on
what they did for me in my life and try
to do that for my kids but yeah when
living navigating that reality when your
parents have died is very intense it's
very you know even little things like
you get in the car so always getting the
car in just call my dad or I call my mom
and I don't do that anymore and I think
one of the that's why I was thinking
today I don't like the idea that someone
passed it they they're dead they've died
there's a permanence to that and that
language and I am always taking to
myself like oh my mom would like that my
dad like that and it real quick gotta
wear my my mom died it wasn't really
into her funeral that I understood that
she died like really grok tit because
someone fell asleep in her funeral and I
thought god my mom would think I totally
love that and then I realized like I
could never tell her that I could never
tell her anything again and those
pillars in your life that you can't go
to in times of joy in times of stress
you know I was in the hospital for
another time for my Crohn's disease my
dad stayed up with me all night he was
there and that part of my life is is
gone now yeah so as a philosophy
professor and as a well-known and
outspoken atheist when you're challenged
with something like the death of a
parent
to any of your beliefs get challenged I
mean is there a moment at you know right
after your dad passed where you thought
and I want to believe or did you maybe
have a dream that seemed different you
know something like that because you
know you know my feelings on here's and
I'm not a believer in the traditional
sense and yet occasionally things happen
that I go what was that after my my
grandma has to us very nervous with
sorry I had some very vivid dreams that
seemed to me she was telling me
something I'm not I'm not saying I buy
it for all this but it has some value
yeah did you have any of that no have
any no no I was just incredibly breathed
and I was it mean it was just a
shattering of a type of reality for me
and but it also made me realize that it
really is true that every moment of life
is precious you just have to be so
grateful go through life with a sort of
gratitude for the experiences that you
have so when you hear someone like me
that you know pretty well say well you
know my grandma passed away and I mean I
can tell you about the dream I was in
her and she would she looked amazing she
was like glowing and she was wearing all
black and she had these like green
beyond streaks in her hair and she was
like running in place really fast and
she was telling me how excited she is
and she has all these things to do I
mean it was it was vivid and powerful
and whatever and so you hear me say
something like that as a non-believer
what do you think of that I think it's
totally normal and totally natural I
think different people grieve in
different ways and I think it was when
my grandfather died I had a similar
experience I had a hyper vivid dream
about him I think these moments in life
life death they're really they give you
a kind of clarity sometimes but they
also get so here so from my dad when
when he had died I was holding my dad's
hand in his at the end of my mom's hand
at her death so I was incredibly
fortunate you know they saw me into the
world I saw them out out of the world
I was just irreconcilable I mean I was
just so I was a complete mess I was
sobbing
the woman who comes in the social worker
what have you said you know normally we
have grief counselors here and normally
I would odds would suggest to say but in
your case I really
I think the state of grief counselor I'm
sending super snotty a grief counselor
and yeah writers and I think part of
that was so hard for me is precisely
because they don't have those
metaphysical beliefs like that's the
finality like that's it so we're so then
did you have moments through these so
you didn't yeah I guess you're saying
you really didn't have a moment where
suddenly but maybe I got this wrong or
or I want to believe in something that I
can't prove but you know I really it's
really that locked for you like oh no
it's not locked I just never borrowed my
hope for anything you know I never I
never have a great life oh yeah well
there's my hope for anything yeah it's
true though I mean I never and then you
go through the long you know I was live
in his house I was driving his cars were
nice clothes because right after we did
the event with christina hoff sommers
the next day that I would I went out
there to see him but yeah it was
fortunate and you know one thing that
people really don't want to talk about I
think the left and the right has their
own blind spots but parenting I am
absolutely convinced is a prophylactic
to bad behavior of good parenting and if
you look at the data kids are more
likely to commit violent crimes if
they're in a certain age group I just
read this in my reading math ones
manuscript above violence and if they're
males and if there's no adult male
president at home and just as the left
doesn't want to acknowledge that and
talk about that so too does the right
have particular blinders about
structural inequality and such but I
think parenting and good parenting and
being thoughtful and what that means
when I was when I was driving down here
the uber driver told me that I'm not
going to mention what country she was
from like at fifty thousand emails I got
these people and no no could you pick a
give me the same hemisphere Southeast
Asia okay third was telling me that they
come from a traditional family and I
asked why doesn't your why don't your
kids go to see your ex and she said well
he used to spank them I thought it why
I've never raised my hand to my children
ever I have raised my voice on the
occasion I never lost my temper it
doesn't speak to me again most attacked
me once or twice in an argument more
than that
that's the other thing it's this idea
about verbal violence it's the idea it's
a complicated but I think parenting
I think we've overlooked how important
that is only thing one thing since we're
talking about yes and play not talking
about this now I have no plan here yeah
the nurse said something really
interesting to me she said I bet you he
was a wonderful father to you and I said
well you say that to everybody and she
actually no I don't I I can tell by the
way the kids treat their parents when
they come to the hospital and this it
was so sad so I would walk into this
hospital every day and I would see all
these people who were literally dying
and they were alone and they had nobody
and it just made me what kind of a
loneliness you know yeah is that the
funny thing about non-belief that you so
obviously had a transcendent experience
yeah but it's all based in actually what
happened so a lot of in reality like I
had a father he was a physical person he
lived in my home he raised me oh and
this you think so I I so what did I do
when my father died after free no sauvé
and the first person I called was my my
childhood friend like the next person
who had known me for the longest time
and he cheered me up and it was good or
he tried to you know that's connected to
the family thing don't you think I've
mentioned this a couple of times lately
that I think now at forty one next week
I started to really understand thanks
I've started to understand why the
family thing is so important that I'm so
proud that my parents have been married
for forty some odd years and I still go
home to the same child at home and my
family friends are also they're my best
friend in the world is still the same
guy that I never had or kindergarten
women were as well but those connections
have incredible value they were totally
that's what you know what is the meaning
of life well you know whatever you make
the meaningless b-but aerosol talks
about that and here's what I would throw
out to you and to the audience is that
you can have the richest deepest most
rewarding friendships if you are a
person of virtue and the person with
whom you're friends with is a person of
virtue our soul says
highest form of friendship between two
virtuous people yeah and we know what
does that entail it really does entail a
kind of Greek parasya speaking truths in
the face of danger
so and I've told you a few things and
you told me a few things hey I think
you're wrong about this so what have you
and if that is sufficient to decide that
we're going to part ways then either a
friendship wasn't that strong in the
first place or I would like to think
that we have the sort of relationship
that we can be completely honest with
each other and even really I wouldn't
spare your feelings about something
frankly yeah which is what you and I
like that's were true friends right and
then I would expect that you would
expect that I wouldn't spare your
feelings that I would just say hey look
man this is how it is you did this and I
have to say and then whatever it was I
was telling you about this right before
we started so without even saying this
the sex or name of the person certainly
or anything like that I got into a bit
of a argument with a friend of my and a
public person just yesterday and we
really got into it on the phone
and I made it clear and I've done this a
couple times lately made it clear with
people that even if were yappa
practically angry at each other this is
not going to end the friendship at least
for me awesome and I feel very it that
comes very easy for me to say that I a
really does and I don't know why that's
so hard for other people to do that
we're so now willing and maybe it is a
social media thing in a short attention
span thing or something like we're so
willing to just shred things that we've
had yet lends itself to a really
interesting question what would be since
we're talking personally if I anchor
what would be a deal breaker for a
relationship and I was at dinner with my
family a few weeks ago and my son you've
met my son got my kid almost always keep
my family's names of stuff I started
talking about one of the things he's
learning about in school is the gender
and social constructs and sex changes
and he said to my wife if dad decided to
become a woman would you still be
married to him and my wife without an
instant of hesitation said no and both
my children were flabbergasted but they
couldn't they could and then they kept
pressing her and she said basically you
know this isn't what I saw
for and and it just made me think so
what are the limits of friendship like
what would the limits of friendship I
mean I can think of a few things well if
you took if I found out that you
murdered somebody yeah cold-blooded
murder or you had done something so
duplicitous directly related to me chief
or even even I would have named even to
someone else or I mean make a scale like
but what if I started filling my pockets
when you're in the kitchen with grapes
and I saw and I told you could have
anything else I know I know right
the funny thing is we never related
about in African anyway thank you so so
like what if I went into your bedroom
when you around and went to your drawers
like there are there are what you know
what those limits are different but I
would I suggest that it really comes
down to virtue and Trust and those sorts
of relationships give your life so much
meaning and are so fulfilling and it's
so profound they make for a life worth
living and that I think what we need to
put front and center in our lives and
even the stuff on addiction is
fascinating
my addiction medicine doctor and she
gave this really interesting
presentation about how one of the the
reasons that people become and stay
addicts and all the studies and this is
a lot of my area of expertise but
basically these studies studies on rat
parks and when rats are given wheels and
fun things habit rails wherever rats
like they're much less likely to choose
narcotics than if they're not and one of
those things is these relationships that
we develop and we nurture throughout our
lives and I guess I would like to be the
sort of person for whom being a person
of integrity and virtue and having those
deeply fulfilling relationships enhances
my life and my friendship and then when
you call me and you say hey this is up
thanks for that I appreciate you did
this and that was a massive dick move
thanks I appreciate that so I know we've
talked about we've definitely talked
about this privately but I think we may
have talked about it last time also but
I think would be good to me if someone
does exactly what you just said define
that virtuous life
but needs to do it through belief yeah
what does the exact same thing do you
think that that is somehow still an
inherent problem with with the proper
not the proper way to be a human but
yeah what's the problem if somebody does
that well there are two to two issues
with that one is what's the problem does
that cause a problem with your
relationship to somebody so I have a
friend who's not only is he a hardcore
Christian he writes children's books
trying to indoctrinate people into
Christian feel Fisher the guy from
vegetabie a very good friend of mine yes
and such so this shows you can be
friends with some weekend and then I've
confided here about things and I trust
him and I have told him and no uncertain
terms
I think he's harboring a not a
misconception but a delusion about the
nature of reality and we've had a civil
to Nolan through fisticuffs no one we
talked about that in the context of our
friendship but that wasn't sufficient
for him to end well I never had any idea
we were talking about to say that wasn't
sufficient for him to withdraw from the
friendship on end the friendship and
that's a core belief and that's an
antithetical belief to what I've devoted
my professional life is to helping
people think clearly and critically and
overthrow dogma and ideology and morally
motivated reasoning but I think the
problem the problem with that is it
depends on what you want to have what
your relationship the truth wants to
issue what you think it should be there
would be something to me if somebody was
friends with me and a genuine friend and
a virtuous friend only because they
feared that if they would not do that
they would go to hell there would be
something suspect in that for me but
what if it wasn't that what if they just
had some belief you know to me like
whatever it is or they just had some
belief that karma proved Cartwright okay
karma is a great they just believe in
karma what they're going to put out
there is going to come back to them thus
because of that they become the virtuous
type of person that you aspire to be
it's a great question I think I've
shifted my stance on that
over the years I guess I'm having
trouble with the question because I
don't really think someone can truly be
virtuous if they Harbor beliefs based on
a faulty epistemology right so we could
tour to get lost all right but my
definition of her truth right but let's
just say that's the case would the world
would be better off in human flourishing
would be contributed to if more people
had this false belief view than if we
resorted to this Hobbesian state yeah I
guess the problem would be if they alone
believed that and didn't try to
institutionalize that I think it would
be it would be less of a problem than I
would have said even two or three years
ago yeah and I think perhaps and I'll
watch the video again myself
yeah I think you might have answered
that a little bit differently which
shows a flexible mind do you ever fear
that as a public person you say things
you tweet things you do interviews you
go on podcast all those things that
people are going back on you see he two
years ago he said something else I was
like they just want to get you so so
that that should what we really need to
have yeah well that should be a virtue
it should be a virtue that you change
your mind I will admit it's a hard for
me to admit but it's true it's so
difficult when you're constantly under
attack and constantly under siege to say
it's far more difficult not only to say
I made a mistake but like look I really
thought about this and then you get
that's why I've stopped reading my
Twitter mentions or Facebook I'm not
about any of it able because it's just
so filled with hate and rage and even if
you look at the terms we use the more
valence of terms how like flip-flopping
flip-flopping is a negative thing like
you change mind but you should change
your mind yeah if you're commander in
chief and the situation on the ground
changes you didn't have access to that
oh he flip flop about troops in Iraq
about Guantanamo well we live in a
dynamic world where things are in flux
and they change but I have I have found
I have definitely found that being that
sort of person who's not willing to
change my mind but the open on open
admission of that on Twitter or Facebook
has become more difficult as people
ramped up their personal slanders and
attack yeah so I'm very aware of that
that I'm dying to talk to you about this
yeah
dying to talk to you about what's been
gone on with you I've had some strange
things going on we'll get there and just
one second okay so you also had another
sort of attack on you it was sort of
similar to what I had on me but that but
I think you're really onto something
there that I don't think it's somewhat
you know sometimes people will say well
you said this three years ago I used to
like this they'll look at some of my
tweets when I was a far less progressive
yeah no but we used to make fun of white
people for their size yeah you're not
proving me into what are you trying to
prove you're proving that yes I evolved
right oh you change your mind and I wow
this guy had tooken information and as a
result that isn't that your but you're
right rational people do that's what
right that's what you're supposed to do
but you're also right about the the
other point which is that when you're
under attack from people you feel like
everything you're going to say yeah but
everything not having those nice moments
of maiya culpas yeah contrition you know
what else you stopped doing which is
interesting you stop asking questions
and and you might ask the questions
yourself but you you don't want to
articulate those questions or you don't
want to articulate those rebuttals
because you don't you really don't want
to receive 500 emails and shift through
all of you telling your [ __ ] and you
should go die and kill yourself and
people write your name and the walls or
not see it so you stop doing that I mean
like you give an example I was this film
I was in with with Michael Shermer
reasons to believe and I made a comment
about [ __ ] hats these people haven't
put see and any look like we this is not
the image you want to portray and
someone I got an unbelievable amount of
just crazy talk about that but one of
the things I thought was wow I almost
said I I came so close to saying do you
think Martin Luther King would have been
more respected or less respected if he
had a [ __ ] hat on I mean it would have
been the perfect thing to say but I
didn't say it because I didn't want
hundreds of emails and we don't me being
racist yeah so I think we're in a
precarious situation right now and I
think Sam is getting this team
crazy amounts asking questions opening
conversations we need to have those
conversations we need to ask those
questions you talk about that Marisa yes
yeah but Charles Mario even Gary Taubes
the guy whom the the ante sugar guy so
what do you do then if you were in my
position or in Sam's position when I see
some articles written about and so will
Rubin talk to this guy or did entire
this gallon they think this and Rubin
didn't ask them this and all this up Sam
gets this too by the way I mean box did
a yeah really hatchet job hit
represented William in Charles Marie
talked about so on and hit pieces and
and right and and slate just wrote
something about you we're going to talk
about the conceptual penis shortly and
what happened with what's on but all of
those things they add up to us not
having any more conversation because at
some point it's just like all right well
then I'll just tell ya okay boy I'll
just talk to well it's not that I'll
talk to people area good I'll just talk
to people who say nothing that's right
because then I've completely insulated
myself right no it'll really so did I
think what we need to do I think we need
to figure out everybody James Lindsay
actually gave me study and I think it's
absolutely right
co-author of the conceptual opinion we
need to figure out whose voice matters
certain people matter and in general
this hate and vitriol comes from the
least accomplished people who you need
there's a really nice me chin frame to
talk about this their view there's kind
of I'm oversimplified but they're slaves
their situation reality is they're
slaves and they discharge these primal
urges on people it's like the
Australians have this term tall poppy
syndrome when that something grows high
you just cut it down as Rubin grows and
subscribers and that's where if I just
cut Rubin down you know [ __ ] kind of
that Nazi white supremists homophobe
yeah so we gay married you not the on
the book right I don't know I don't know
but until avoid but we have to figure
out whose voices matter yeah and then we
need to we need to have those
friendships of virtue so when people
come to us and say something we can
really listen but the way to not do it
is to look at as you said repeatedly to
look at an egg on
Twitter yeah it's probably a 12 year old
in their basement we just can't take
those voices seriously all right so sort
of couched around everything we're
talking about so far is is sort of good
and evil but tonight fix that some
people use to be involved in a
conversation the motives that we had
whether it be because you're a believer
or a non-believer anyhow I've come to a
place where I think right now in 2017
we're in a strange spot where they're
sitting
the the institutions that used to help
us keep some of the stuff in the lanes
what what is acceptable what's not
acceptable what's right and wrong what's
real and not real you know whether it's
true or not that these institutions are
crumbling and by that I mean that media
is crumbling our political institutions
seem to be car active are not you can
make institution so that's the way I
really want to get into with you all of
these things are starting to crumble
it's partly because information has
changed so much I'll adore it even worse
than crumble but what you would say
they're they're decimated already no no
I would argue that the academy certain
sections of the Academy the sciences I
think are doing very very well
the humanities are in shambles certain
departments anything tainted by
post-modernism particularly Gender
Studies the conceptual piece okay so we
have very poised rejects okay let me
just go to the conceptual penis as a
social conscience as a social contract
right you will wrote a hoax paper with
James Lindsay right and you got this
publish that we thought was extremely
funny it I mean I read it it's a
jaw-droppingly ridiculous yeah and it
argued for climate change being
responsible the conceptual penis yeah
and I thought is really funny as a
satire sort of the main takeaway of it
is that the penis is not really a real
thing it's just this sort of amorphous
idea and we threw in a lot of moral
jargon we threw no we appeal to their
moral sensibilities okay so why pee
you're an academic why would you write a
hoax paper why would you mock the very
institutions of which you are maybe
because I think that there are
departments in the universities that are
making a mockery of our institutions so
when you said crumbling I don't think
that's that's not the word I would have
used although it's accurate in a sense
but these
people are fabricating not only their
own knowledge bases they're writing
things in journals that they then fight
that becomes knowledge they have their
manufacturing ideas that are totally
untethered to reality this is how crazy
this is
so let's look I'm going to explain it
I'm going to try explaining this you
real me and if this is unclear okay but
this is idea is so crazy that anybody
listening to this exams that can't
possibly this this can't possibly show
so this is the idea and then I'm going
to give you you're asking you a belief
I'm going to give you an analog and
theology so what these people do is that
they have moral intuitions based upon
Marxist thought basically I'll get to
that a second so what they do to justify
this is they manufacture their own
epistemology their own way to know that
justifies the conclusions that they have
so then they can go out and become
activists now quick detour yeah one of
the biggest problems facing the left
right now is anybody who calls out a bad
idea is viewed as somebody on the right
we've got to stop that I know a little
something about you know a little
something about this yeah a lot about
this so let's i'ma give you an analogy
in theology so this guy alvin
plantinga's is a Christian philosopher
so he has these beliefs these are
actually one that they're claims about
reality and about Jesus being the Son of
God so he realizes that there's no
evidence that can take him there usually
so what does he do he manufactures his
own epistemology he said well you know
we're going to say that there's this
thing called the God sensor and the God
sensor some people have it and it allows
you to just as I apprehend the color red
so to do I apprehend God so he makes an
epistemology to justify these insane
claims about the nature of reality so
just as he has done that critical theory
is that epistemology that is used and I
can explain that is complicate I'm a
friend of Italy we're all right we got a
lot of terms we got
very complicated but what I would like
to attempt to do in this segment is to
link the madness on campuses right now
to the intellectual engines driving that
madness and and the make no mistake
about it these departments tainted by
post-modernism are absolutely filled
with zealots and morally motivated
either ideologues okay so let's say I'll
do a little catch up so that in case
anyone's missing in it
so first let's let's talk about what is
post-modernism I know but I know most
are located that but let's just let's
just do a couple definitions quick okay
so let's do a definition so okay so the
Frank ports Frankfurt School has this
idea of what even go back for it let's
go back to Karl Marx Karl Marx was a
philosopher who here's a bonus question
why did Hitler hate call Marx I feel
like there's a good punch line well it's
not a joke such as you can you know do
anything the Jews touched work Oh God in
there but otherwise in a letter they a
great guy no no okay so so Marx Marxist
economics and these people aren't
Marxist they're more Marxian would be a
better term marchia economics looks at
the world in terms of economic
oppression there are oppressor classes
etc so they have and then we'll get to
the idea of postmodern is very it's
simple and complicated so they've taken
this idea of these Marxian notions of
oppressor classes and look at them in
terms of gender and race and for example
the patriarchy and then they have
hierarchically prioritized people within
that list so the patriarchy is white
heterosexual cisgendered which is the
thing males and they want her at the top
of it or a bag but I am absolutely
talking there and but that's the other
thing they do just like religion they
have their own defense mechanisms and
that's what they say well you can't
criticize it because your assist
gendered white heterosexual male and is
the ultimate irony of this that is
prejudice that is prejudging
okay because I because I then sit here
and go wait a minute
okay here bagozzi and a white straight
cisgendered male yeah I really judge you
based on your immutable characteristic
talk about so you are using words based
upon normal ordinary definition I'll
give you example some more it's like so
when you use racism it's the way I use
roots with most people who aren't in
haven't been indoctrinated by gender
studies in the postmodern left it's the
idea that you do not judge people
particularly negatively but you don't
make judgments about people based upon
an immutable characteristic like their
skin color but they've changed that
definition to make it systemic racism
they've changed that definition to put
in a power vector the hierarchical power
vector that only flows one way so for
example and this blacks cannot be racist
against whites so they have snuck it's
very sneaky they've taken a normal word
added a moral component to it and change
the definition of a word you know here's
some if I may give you some more
examples like equality equality is a
good day but they have shifted from
equality to equity now what is equity
mean
equity means well we need certain number
of people representative of the general
population 70% African Americans we need
to have seventeen percent but the
problem is the dat that they also want
to take in to account historical
discrimination and a kind of reparations
for that so those numbers are even
higher so it's I think it can be
summarized in Ruth Bader Ginsburg's quip
or joke where there is how many female
Supreme Court justices do you think
there should be nine so it's not just
right it's not just that we want equal
representation higher we want more
because of past and justices go ahead
because this is this get we got to talk
about deconstruction we got to talk
about violence because our about why but
all these things when you understand
them from this mindset they're all
coming from the same school of thought
affected by critical theory that
the most amount of defined critical
theory yeah so critical theory is this
idea that you that traditional power
dynamics and traditional but and this is
oversimplified but it's a general idea
from which we can have a starting point
for a conversation yeah so that's again
I thought to myself I'm going to get 500
emails says it and just China and it
makes me it again it it makes me self
sensor and then I'm like come on yeah ok
but that's real that's a real I want to
get lost now yeah that is a real thing I
mean I find it for myself as I try to
talk broadly about things because I want
to communicate big ideas and hopefully
people will then read some books or
watch some other videos or write follow
some other people on Twitter whatever
and then even if you talk about it will
be well you see he yeah he wrecked over
that right or he did another time
why don't he talk about the Frankfurt
School like we didn't mention Horkheimer
wants are doing or all these guys are
left guys and you know just you just get
to a point where all of that centering
it's essentially just it's not it
diminishes the message it's not good for
you it's not good for conversations it's
not good for okay so anyway it's why I
mentioned the think juez issue and I
thought that was in either yeah or into
that will Inquisition right now if you
think for yourself and you are not
afraid to buck the trend you know will
come to get you it's exactly right so
critical here so it's the idea that the
it's basically a Marxist idea it's the
idea that there are these entrenched
power structures and entrenched power
dynamics and one of the things that when
you do is we need to recognize these and
then we need to over those we need to
deconstruct these traditional
hierarchies to make society more that's
the thing more equitable more family
what is it what is it it's complicated
so these kids protesting and evergreen
or have them just ex nihilo just get
this idea that they just going to it
just it no they get this these are
coming out of specific departments in
the university and when they're asked
you know why do you do this or what is
this
they tell my professor said this and
then this
the insane part that gets back to the
conceptual greenness again that these
people have their own lines of
literature that is these are
intellectual cesspools
the hem that's going to get now so they
have their egg and all right so I'm that
are you yeah that day have manufactured
what they think that's why they have to
like with cultural appropriation they
have to import ideas like power because
it isn't if the whole thing is made up
it's completely fabricated because they
want to use they want to overthrow these
traditional hierarchies so these kids
get this idea from their professors who
then get promoted in tenure because they
publish in journals and their stuff is
almost never cited by anybody but yet
that's how you rise up and then what
happens is you have a whole canon of
knowledge and you go out and teach
people and and then you have diversity
training and the shame of this whole
thing is that there is legitimacy to
white power
there is legitimacy to some of this
stuff but the way that it's metastasized
almost doesn't allow any kind of
liberation it does almost the exact
opposite of what they want to do because
it gets you people like Trump but one
more thing was saying yeah but but then
what happens is it goes to colleges of
education and then they start teaching I
think I told you my son has in his
geography a geography civics a camera
where I look at stuff he doesn't they've
never even opened a map they've never
opened a map they've never in civics
class how many Supreme Court justices
legislative branch something sent none
of that stuff but he knows everything
about the Black Panthers but he knows
everything about the civil rights the
civil rights movement is extremely
important wonderful stuff but it should
not we need to look into that we need to
know what countries above can it be
really all of this stuff gets back to
certain departments in the university
that are pumping out nonsense that are
indoctrinating people and exactly like a
religion they have their own defensive
structures they're you know being
offended is the new thing inclusion is
another word that they've changed the
meaning of
so there is a direct line between is
this coming is this clear so far I'm
whether they're to me yeah okay so
there's a judge with the audience okay
so because if it's not clear something
needs to happen so they want to
overthrow these traditional hierarchies
and they have manufactured their own
base of scholarship to do so so have I
it's worse than crumbling because at
least if something crumbles something
worse didn't take its place like if in a
lot like it's like having an alarm clock
that rings randomly so it's worse than
just having an arm clock that doesn't
work it's there pumping out fabricated
nonsense that's totally untethered to
reality and the moment you call these
people out on it they don't believe in
dialogue anyway they'll still slander
you the write your name on the bathroom
wall they'll scream at you so the only
thing to do you got a hoax in you you've
got to have a non-traditional way to
deal with people who are so
fundamentally irrational that they're
not going to have a conversation and
that led you to writing this hoax yeah
and turning this thing on its head
alright there was sort there when I get
to so first off what's the connection
with the religious mind until ad
wonderful because it strikes me as the
new religion that in a very right
politics but but this leftist postmodern
Marxist stuff that this is the new
religion they they mana nor Vega
everyone else for their beliefs all
right but they have a belief that is so
tethered to their own being that if you
challenge it in any way they out cable
they'll hate you but they'll write
outcasts anyone get one 100% correct and
what do you say about that movement so
that is an awesome question so are you
Lindsay and I wrote everyone every wrote
it wrote a paper again privileges the
original sin for the left so but there
is one fundamental difference you're
you're having Shermer and Prager coming
to the studio in debate and it's going
to be civilized no one's going to punch
each other they have fundamental
actually very fundamental just moral
disagreement and try me there one of
them Prager blends that you cannot have
morality without God and and Shermer
believes the complete opposite so this
is powerful stuff I fav agree and
they're gonna have a dialogue yeah about
that I don't live in a score I don't
know if it's a debate I
I don't really I'm not a fan of it
having a conversation is much better but
so so you have the same mechanisms in
the in this new secular religion you
have privilege which is a type of
original sin you have blasphemy laws
which are political correctness wait
let's just really clear that yeah so
when you say that privilege is the
original said that's like saying Jesus
died for your sins basically like your
if you were born white and any
cisgendered had a reciting all that [ __ ]
that you are yeah that you are there's
nothing you can did yet today okay and
this is the part that except now this is
a part that's the mind blow and this is
the part that makes me unbelievably
sympathetic to Christians in particular
as opposed other religious that's really
changed my mind significantly Christians
have a Redemption narrative these people
have no redemption narrative if you're
privileged that's it you're [ __ ] like
you there's no redemption from you you
can down hard verse yeah yeah and I
thought yeah so there's something about
being able to be redeemed these people
don't have and that's why you see these
vitriolic attacks they are merciless on
other people on the left eating other
people on the left the oberus you know
the snake that eats itself yeah so we're
okay a lot of there yeah so yeah so it
is a new secular religion and they have
maybe we have modules in our brain I
don't know and maybe it's covariant
there with culture there are things in
the culture and act in our brain and we
have the same thing we have in Jonathan
Highness to talk to us we have purity
versus sanctity maybe we have you know
ways of interpreting reality but make no
mistake this is a secular religion and
when you call out the Empress for having
no clothes you that is that you have
committed you are in trouble right which
I think has a bit to do of the recent
hatchet jobs that have been done on me
and you so sleep basically wrote a piece
about you after this whole thing right
and it really was kind of straw matting
what you did but the attacks are also
kind of personal and that's there's
always is it interesting you know when
Salon goes after me or you or slate goes
out to me or you or Sam Harris whoever
they go after there's a kind of animus
there's a kind of
personal attack that is not just a an
engagement of maybe hey look you know
you did this this is why it's not right
right you know it's not oh yeah maybe
it's funny but you're wrong about this
and here's what I owe any plea personal
attack on someone's like I called them
on the phone I think I emailed in at
least 120 times I said look you guys
wrote this about me I would like an
opportunity to respond to this mm-hmm
nothing then I went on Twitter and I
said hey can I please have an
opportunity so I won't say I know the
exact wording was but can i I'd like an
opportunity nothing I would like an
opportunity that's a nice thing in
journalism like you just write hit
pieces on someone and then you don't
give an out to 1988 I think it is I
think what's starting to happen is that
because journalism because mainstream
journalism is crumbling yeah I still use
that that adjective there and and nobody
cares about CNN anymore and even the New
York Times I think has gone in a really
terrible direction because they love a
lot of the ideas that you're talking
about but since the institutions are
crumbling well now everybody just picks
their website that they authorized those
websites are funded by all sorts of
different things and if you've got an
editor who has bought in to your
postmodern [ __ ] in their case well
you know you could say whatever the hell
you want about Pete or Dave or whoever
else yeah and you're going to get
backing so for this whole craziness that
happened with wicked mother goes up yeah
intrusive and remove from that right
right which has been reformed and to
present for this editor so they the
title of the thing was about the the new
extreme is further to the right now we
have to talk about that so you have
talked about have to be out of your mind
or or or just a liar of the highest
order to think that of me you can hear
you can criticize me for all you want I
address criticism on here if people
think I don't have the right question
yeah and I run and it's not just that
he's a terrible journalist he has a
religious mindset like this is a
religion to these people so that so
that's the interesting thing so then I
went on the full-on I mean I was like
you know what you picked the wrong
person to [ __ ] with right and I went on
the absolute attack
I was defended publicly by Union rogen
and a whole slew of other people to the
tens of thousands of retweets and things
of that and then various two days ago he
was writing about how no
doesn't believe I'm an extremist but he
doesn't a debt you know there's no
public correction they do slight things
at the end of the article but no one can
ever see Wikipedia I still run with the
real thing he knows I Ted the editor
this woman Clara Jeffrey and all the in
all the tweets she never responds she's
never gotten this much Twitter traction
but they don't feel a need to because
they know that their monster is just
going to keep moving forward and that's
what I'm trying to figure out the answer
so just to be clear you and so what did
he say about your show well sort of it
the title and you can look at this maybe
it still is pin tweet right now though I
suspect he's either deleted it or
removed it all together was something
about the rise of the new extremism or
the newest extremists that are further
to the right than Breitbart then he
includes me in that where he refers to
me as far-right then eventually changed
that to just right right widget the
right less thing doesn't even make any
sense anymore I can put all that aside
as I mentioned that the top Forbes
called this a conservative show last
week I've said to you I think you were
the first one I ever said it to that
defending my liberal principle is
becoming a conservative position so all
of these labels are starting to make no
sense and that's just what's happened
here that and that's their thing so a
couple of things here if you had an
itemized checklist if you just write
your beliefs down and you check you and
I would both overwhelmingly fall into
the liberal camp not the left camp right
so msy be saying liberal is not left
that is the chromatics mistake people
make but just to be clear for you yeah
so without naming the person who wrote
the article the guy who are the article
well mate yeah Josh Harkins
okay yeah is Josh invited on your show
yeah I invited immediately I said I like
no is he still invited on your show and
he wrote something sorry why offer I
first I said got you come on my show
I'll give you the first ten minutes
without talking he didn't respond to
that then today finally days later I
responded again say or which the day
we're taping this exam is off of when
we're airing it but today I wrote you
know will you come on the show you hack
so then I was being a little more
heavy-handed under well I won't come on
could you call me a name huh I mean
he'll they wouldn't come on
so the hacker I was just excuse even
yeah but you suggest to be completely
clear agree right
they're feminine so you'd come on you
can sit here in ten minutes I will sit
here and I will have a theme and I
invited the editor too by the way she's
welcome to come on all that but but in
an odd way
maybe that and someone pointed this out
to me either one of the strange odd same
voices said Dave that would be the worst
thing you could do because what we're
doing is you're encouraging more people
to do things your Jean people to say
crazy things about you you then get in a
huff puff and you got to defend yourself
and now what's the next thing now you
got a you got a sit and take it on your
own show which is so completely against
the ideas that you care about like I
don't want my life to be that you know
you mean and that's I want my life to be
that either yeah yeah so it's it's a nod
to communicate is you don't want to just
ignore it it's against human nature to
be attacked and to just sit down and
take that's why we talked before about
you have to figure out whose voices
matter no at the end and I mean I don't
know anything about this guy but does
his voice matter to you I mean is this
guy's opinion no he's it utterly
irrelevant to me but he wrote a piece in
a publication that had saw so so the
publication has been relevant and by the
way this guy as I mentioned at the top
also he was one of 40 people that the
Virginia GOP baseball game shooter
followed yeah so we know that that guy
was was riled up by a lot of the
political stuff he was reading because
you could just live on his Facebook and
all that to see that and how much he
hated Republicans whatever so if you're
calling me an extremist there's a cost
now that ideas and intentions matter
which is why I think you can attack the
hell out of ideas I do that you did not
can you should you know what doesn't
mean you should be instigating violence
and and therein lies the rub hmm how do
you feel now about all the smell that
has been a day behind you did you do
feel angry when it happened on Friday I
was I was livid I was in New York City
and I was walking me in the middle of
Times Square so I'm in Times Square the
craziest place on earth like you know
stimulation via bananas and whatever and
I'm just freaking off Twitter and I'm
calling people and like I'm going to
destroy them and everything else and you
know some people said to me this is the
very definition of libel because it's
democracy untrue he's attacking your
income source because of the reference
to patreon or all these other things
to see the guy buy it by the way I've
been on the record saying I am for
libelous I'm a free speech absolutist
but there are laws that we have related
to libel that's a secondary thing but
then on on Monday when it calmed down
when I got home from New York on the
other day night you know this because
you're in my house right now I came home
and my dog was lathering around Anna
she's 13 I love love love this dog with
every fiber of my being
she she was a rescue from Hurricane
Katrina I've had her you know for 11
years and she was staggering and she was
having trouble standing and she looked
confused and Roger gone around and then
I spent the night and we had to bring
her at the Animal Hospital overnight we
just got her back today and she has some
issues that were hopefully going to work
on but it completely put everything in
Persia animal yeah more important to me
than this [ __ ] right without Quentin
it doesn't mean I'm not going to get
robbed that's real listening but my love
of this animal perhaps what we talked
about before about relationships in and
you have really I have two dogs two
kinda crazy dogs but those relationships
matter and in that sense they they not
supersede or not override but it made
you refocus on what mattered like I
could be doing all this stuff like that
thing in Private Ryan that's seen where
the guys like saying we got to do this
we do this and he gets a bullet in the
head yeah
you know like now you have a sick animal
you know like your dog is sick and you
love your dog and I don't know I guess
it's interesting I don't know whether or
not having him on would be a mistake or
not because it would encourage other
people to do the same thing yeah well I
know it would because it's a feeding
frenzy
we have you guys operate we've seen this
before with many so wouldn't even
college yeah what do you think his
motivation well I mean I know you can't
really I don't well that's no way what
is the motivation because I believe that
it's exactly what you're talking about
that it's this religious you were what
was the word to you there was this
religious quasi religious or moral
emotive area that a secular religion
secular really a it's this secular
religion that they so believed so I
veered off the path to these guys it
doesn't matter that
gay married doesn't matter in pro-pot
doesn't matter that I'm pro-choice it
doesn't matter that I'm for euthanasia
the checklist to check us all the way
now and and one side is religious and
this is why I talk about the left more
because on the right even though they
know I'm all of those things
I still get invited places I get put on
Prager you videos I get invited to
college kids that want to talk to me
they put aside all the different I was
at a libertarian students for liberty
thing I said I'm for single-payer health
care libertarians don't like that they
booed me but then laughed we laughed
about it and I kind of mocked them boo
boo me guys we're the tolerant one you
know guys and they got it yeah I don't
get any invites the other way so so
that's why I think that phrase is so
perfect because this is to be religious
it is the new religion why do you think
you don't get MSNBC doesn't have you on
I don't know
I can't beg them I was on Fox last week
Greg Gutfeld which i think is a great
guy who's going to come on in here yeah
really doing good stuff we disagree on
some stuff okay Big Damn look yeah
I can't beg them why does why does Fox
put on ion and MSNBC does you see that
maybe dr. Sanjay we wonderful quite on
the demand that we should demand an
answer did you see last week that here
uh last week Hulk what's his name after
two plays Hulk the actor that plays Hulk
somebody help me here Mark Ruffalo oh
yeah the thing about you know MSNBC is
hiring these white conservatives and
it's so interesting because he's judging
people's political opinions on their
skin color number one that he's a white
guy who plays a green guy so there's
something but you know you must as a
philosophy professor Mary there's got to
be some deep [ __ ] there but even putting
that aside if they started hiring a
bunch of black conservatives he wouldn't
be happy about that either dan would
accuse them of being Uncle Tom's or
something we are probably can part it's
like Clarence Thomas yeah we need more
Supreme Court justices but there but to
like would you rather have more so
Clarence Thomas's on the Supreme Court
would you rather have more white
liberals on the Supreme Court so what do
you think is they have to go to this
because I've been trying to push the
ideas of classical liberalism as you
know I believe that the individual is
the only antidote to this if you
relentlessly stand for the individual
you will always stand for our
differences you will always be tolerant
of our differences because you will
realize that you're different than the
next guy you won't look at somebody and
prejudge them based on color or say I
have to treat them like there are some
bright amol because they have this level
of oppression where the okay you put you
put your finger on the problem so let's
talk about the opposite problem
intersectionality is the problem we
haven't talked about that but that there
is grievance jockeying dad said the
oppression Olympics etc we we need the
opposite of internet intersectionality
and and we need Union ality and there's
a line of literature called a super
ordinate identities so let's unpack that
real quick have you seen the Heineken
commercial yes it's incredible I love it
amazing everything that I've tried to do
here ok so that's what we need now we
don't need can you just weigh it out
real quick for well the highly commended
you lay out the Heineken call so they
just basically get people together who
you think have nothing to do with each
other or should win yeah right political
enemies or personal enemies and they sit
down over a drink and do it and they
general conversation yeah well that
maybe they've been met sex no no they do
some tasks like this and hard tasks and
then at the end they say you won't have
a beer yeah and they say yeah and then
they talk it's an example of a of Union
ality as opposed intersectionality we're
not grieving we're not trying to find
out who has the most strikes against
them who's the most depressed and then
they get the most to get the rights to
talk the BLM can over over can talk to
the pride march or what have you what we
need to do is oh the shooting in
Virginia right now we need to appeal to
larger identities and we need to
coalition build and I see the left over
and over again continuing to dig down in
identity politics continuing to use
intersectionality to find the most
marginalized and oppressed groups and
then to attempt to change either the
nature of words either/or and the
structure of the rule sets in our
institutions to
these folks John Rawls had this whole
thing solved but I think superordinate
identities finding identities and things
that we have in common and working to
build coalitions and I and I think if we
if the left continues to do that will
either get another four years of Trump
or that other lunatic pants it right
it's we need to build ident it's so
funny that you describe it that way
because your area you're talking about
post-modernism you're talking about
cultural Marxism all this stuff and yet
so people will go well people P+ be
right you must be on the right you must
be some sort of evil conservative or not
and yet you're not know and and I do
more I'm by the way I don't want to use
conservative as I said inspector I don't
want to use it as a pejorative at the
thing I don't feel at home
I no longer and maybe it's because I'm
oddly situated that's another word they
love I'm oddly situated in the Academy
in Portland which is very leftist center
anyway even though the overwhelming
majority of my beliefs I would call self
identify as a classical liberal I no
longer feel at home
no with anything to do with things that
are even broadly the left and you and
other people have called for the new
center I think that might be what we
need I certainly don't feel at home in
the right and again in terms of that
checklist of beliefs they have so I feel
that I'm efficient because I kind of
feel like when I live in Albuquerque I
feel that I'm wandering not wandering I
feel that I've I don't have a home and I
don't feel comfortable anywhere but one
of the consequences of not feeling
comfortable is when you meet people who
share those beliefs you have a kind of
ideological kinship you have a kind of
wow we're really on the outs here right
there we're really trying to figure this
out we're really trying to make so we
try to live a good life we're trying to
be decent people we're trying to make
decisions on the basis of evidence and
yeah we change our minds and but we're
not at home on the right we're not at
home on the Left we're being excoriated
on the on the left for calling out never
make calling out somebody's [ __ ] a
right-wing thing the moment you've done
that you're you've become a farce a
caricature of yourself it's a farce you
know it's so interesting you've hit on
so many things because I love what we're
doing here because it's we're talking
about this sort of
broad issues but then also how they are
directly related to us yeah as people
and that's what I think really matters
and even you know just a week ago or so
I think it was in Philadelphia they
unveiled their new gay pride rainbow
flag but now it has a black and brown
color bar you know two new color bars to
represent people of color and this is
the height of absurdity the rainbow flag
represented all gay people white gay
people Asian gay people's Muslim gay
people Jewish gay people etcetera
etcetera
there was no racial connotation to it
and the gay community at least from what
I can tell is pretty good on on most
racial issues you see more couples I
think that are racially different or
diverse or all that stuff but now
because they had to bow to whatever that
I don't know who's directly related to
black lives matter or whatever but
because they had to bow to them they
literally ruined the rainbow the rainbow
is we know what the rainbow is now
they're telling us the rainbow is
inherently part of the patriarchy or
racist or in essence is like I didn't
end the push but here's the ring all
right
so I thought all this obviously I don't
think I'm blowing anyone's mind when I
say this they understand what I think
but I didn't even want to tweet about it
because I didn't even feel like getting
involved on this one it's like I picked
my battles and if I was available so we
do that you're racist you don't want a
black bar and a brown bar but my point
would be there was no racial kind of
right you're now making it racist all
right and guess what somebody yours from
now is going to have some other thing
that they want to put on there and there
you have to make sure they're more
oppressed than you right and this is the
endless snake eating itself
yeah don't say it just within that you
know I'm thinking about Emma being sick
I think that's one of the things that
people don't see when they attack you I
think that's one of the things that
people don't like you're just a guy
living your life you've got a dog you've
got a husband you're trying to make to
the day like everybody else and I think
people need to take a step back and
realize that we're actually people dave
rubin is a guy and he's a good guy and
he likes Heineken or you know I'm saying
yeah odd guy way more four or five
people and if you have a problem with
somebody it's much better and it's not
necessarily the tone of the criticism
and I you know feel a feel we're gonna
start don't act a rumor does it you know
I don't think you're not gonna don't
exactly I people to do whatever they
want to do anyway but I think that you
would get more mileage and more
attention if those criticisms were
devoid of personal attacks and you said
we've been said this this is why I think
it's wrong and you lay it out well as I
said before when people have attacking
Dave you didn't ask this question you
asked a question around where you you
you know my policy on interviewing is I
like to give rope to let people hang
ourselves look I just ask you a lot of
really broad question if you didn't know
where you were talking about you want to
hung yourself I in this instance I don't
think you did but I've had guests that I
think do but those I those are
criticisms I'm more than happy to
address and I hope that five years from
now I'm so much of a better interviewer
that I look back on this and think this
is [ __ ] or I want to be better I wanted
that but if you're a if you're going to
jumping-off point is these guys are
right-wing extremists well then we're
not going to really do this but I think
what we've done here for the hour is
pretty good we're going to wrap this
thing and we're going to dinner with
some friends cuz we didn't make up the
friendship thing work
no it's illegitimate no it wasn't an
artifact of uh say yeah when I get
drunker with probably yeah probably I'm
only supposed to my died amount of low
sugar diet didn't still so I'm only
supposed to drink Pinot Grigio now so
I've been drinking a ton of that so I
think that's our I like the red but I
mean everything alright it was a
pleasure as always
and and we have to do these more than
once a year because I think it's a good
it's a good catch up and it's a good I
have no problem you grading whether I've
moved forward or or rest or whatever I
think it would be a fun thing yeah and
and who knows where our ideas are going
to go who knows how our beliefs will
change when we've confronted but new
evidence but here's what we do know if
either one of us thinks that we've gone
off the rails or that we've made a
mistake
we're going to call it out to the other
one and we're going to do so in the
context of a friendship well said
for more on Peter Bogosian or Bogosian
he doesn't mind which way you say it
follow them on the Twitter although he
may not checkers mentions that much at
Peter be lithium
[Music]
you